just wanted to get back into the car and
drive after she crashed into our
driveway okay and she's giving us a hard
time okay and she says because she's a
principal she doesn't want us to call
the cops I call the cops not going to
the way that you want
it understand that I understand that how
you guys doing I understand that but you
cannot go home like this I just
ex come come come Hi how are you
who I just have to go to the bathroom
really really bad you're involved in
hold on I didn't hit anything do me a
favor and go back walk walk was this
with thank you what what happened I just
have to go to the bathroom sir really
bad but you're not you're not answering
my questions for me yes sir what
happened I just have to go to the
bathroom no that's not the question that
I asked you question my question that
I'm asking you is what happened nothing
I came over here I took a picture I came
over here I I just took go the bathroom
Polie off hey hey
boss ma'am ma'am ma'am ma'am ma'am
you I just have to go to the bathroom
but again I need you to continue telling
me what happened with this accident I
just have there was no accidents sir
there was
no look look look at your vehicle I look
at the vehicle okay hold on hold on hold
go to the bathroom you're not
understanding me I need you to look
where your vehicle is right I need you
to see that all of your airbags have
deployed they have you do not have shoes
on right now I took them off in the car
cuz I came out to speak to you
sir accident the car I just stepped over
to the side I really have to go to the
bathroom sir please that's all I'm
asking go to the bathroom and I'll be
fine I'm leaving West Orange I'm 5
minutes away I got you I'm fine I just
have to go to the bathroom okay but this
accident you're not answering my
question you're saying that you pulled
to the side how did you pull to what
caused all of this I pulled to the side
because ask to take a picture I see go
the bathroom sir please ask
please
please I just need to go the bathroom
one hold on hold on
Ma I promise you there's no vehicle
inside the residence
just a regular motor vehicle CR I just
have to go to the
bathroom that's all I asked I asked to
go to the bathroom are you injured ma'am
no ma'am no sir okay you're you're not
you're not injured no okay no I'm fine I
just have to go to the bathroom can you
just get the license registration
insurance for me please yes sir can I
just go to the bathroom please I I need
I need to I need to deal with this first
and then then we could proceed I just
have to go to the bathroom I can't hold
it I'm just being I cannot hold it I
understand man but right now you're
involved in a motor vehicle accident I'm
not I'm a driveway you are this is not
your driveway is this your driveway not
my driveway I pulled over because they
asked me just pull over I have to go to
the bathroom I'm just asking you can I
please go to the bathroom sir ma'am
that's all I have to do ma'am let me let
me ask you a question here yes sir okay
have you have you been drinking today
earlier today I was earlier today you
got yes can you check
un
sir I just to go the bathroom
understandable I pulled over okay and
when I
stopped the air po the bag because I
stopped
short but you see I didn't hear anything
I L have to go theath I can't do this
please I'm s I'm asking my father is a
retired Stant detective in New
York in there sh I have to go to the
bathroom I'm absolutely fine I'm fine
was I am sir pass I just have to go to
the bathroom and I just stopped to go to
the bathroom and when I stopped short it
had to go to the bathroom and want I'm
fine I'm fine
that's that's it they're going to have
somebody
coming
can you get your license
registration okay we want to thank
Morgan and Morgan for sponsoring this
body cam video I mean I think it's
pretty clear from the body cams that we
cover that it's not always safe out
there when you're hurt it can be
confusing it can be scary you don't
really know where to turn well Morgan
and Morgan is actually the largest
injury law firm in America and in a time
when you already have so much to think
about they're going to make it super
easy for you they have completely
modernized the process because you
submit your claim you sign contracts you
upload documents you talk to your whole
legal Team all on your phone that's it
an attorney is going to review your case
in just 8 clicks also they have 4,000
support staff that can help you too
which is just amazing to think about and
in terms of price well you only pay them
if you win there's no upfront fee so if
you're injured and you want to join the
over three million people that call them
every year you can submit a claim at
www. forthepeople.com
elcam or by dialing pound law that's
pound 529 on your
[Music]
phone
you's okay yeah that's the best
thing
um here start driver vehicle she just
had to stop to the bathroom she ended up
hitting I didn't hit anything I just
need to stop I have to go to the
bathroom I'm fine my license just fell
there I have my driver's license it fell
there it fell where Insurance it fell on
the side sir I just have to go to the
bathroom okay and I just pulled I had to
really go to the bathroom really bad
okay I'm fine I promise you my father is
a retired s detective in New York he is
unfortunately deceased I just have to go
to the bathroom I'm I'm sorry for your I
just want to go I just have to go to the
bathroom that's it I didn't hit anything
do do you mind can you get your license
for me it's on the side and I cannot
reach it because of my bracelet okay you
mind I go in there to get your driver's
license
have them evaluate you
please
um yeah yeah that's that's the thing
[Music]
yeah not
even I think I think it comes
back
[Music]
Mr the house Mr the cars yeah I mean the
car came out that car was house that's
why I'm thinking like it's I see all of
you here
[Applause]
right I mean as of right now we're just
trying to assess the situation all
right you can see
that I that I will tell you I've seen
her earlier I I I know that you that
doesn't yeah I'm I'm just trying to just
trying to assess the situation and see
where it goes from
there is everybody okay though anybody
hurt no I mean she she seems that she's
uh she's not
injured no she was quick to get out she
said she was okay but it's like it's
still very shocking right right right do
you live in that's nice car that she
missed by the grace of
God she wanted to get back in her car
and leave and I'm like you need to get
attention H can't dve like that their
guys deployed I know like can't shrick
your car so we we were just trying to
get her to sit and she just you know
she's not in the right St so gotcha okay
all right let me let me let me talk toor
stay here thank you I have to bom that's
all we going to run do test okay let's
let's let's get
moving I'm sorry just just stand right
here for me
please I really have to go the bathro
you need to understand me all right
understand what I'm telling you right
now okay I'm asking you do you mind
going through a fil sobriety test with
me I'm fine I just really have to go to
the bathroom not answering the question
sir I'm going to urinate on myself and
I'm asking you I have a bladder problem
okay my father is a retired Sergeant New
York I have to go to the bathroom I'm
going to urinate on myself and I'm
asking you if if we can get these tests
done the faster we can get these tests
done the faster you can use the bathroom
I can't you're not I have to go to the
bathroom you have two you have two
options at this point okay you either
take this test right yes or you get
locked up okay I'll take the test by
really okay sir I got you like like I
said you take the test or you come with
me and cuss those are the only two
options that I'm giving you right now I
will take the test I have I understand
you have to the test I have to do the
test before you use the bathroom I'm
just saying I have to we understand you
have been telling me that you have to
use the bathroom since I got here that's
it okay I got you take the tou I
can't over here you see these cffs right
take this test or you're coming in
handcuffs your book
on please sir I'm asking you I have to
go to the bathroom please I'm going to
run a f sobriety test with you I
anything okay I'm going to run a fiety
test with you I'm going to read these
instructions to you officer I'm going to
read these instructions I did not ask
for this test but I have to go to the
physical bathroom and I'm asking you
respectfully I know ma'am but there's no
bathrooms around here we're on the side
of the road I'm saying is I pulled over
because she was like okay pull over I
pulled over I have to go to the bathroom
I I I understand that if there's no
bathrooms around here for you to go I
Live 5 minutes away in
West yes okay all right well you're not
going to be able to get there right now
I can I just really have to we're going
to have we're going to have to do these
tests okay so my partner's going to read
from a book aloud and I'm going to
demonstrate the test so you can see it
and then you're going to perform I
understand that but you're not going to
piss in that bush over there I'm not you
have to yell at me okay but I mean
you're a broken record right now you
don't have to yell at me but I'm saying
to you I have a
documented the bathroom and all I'm
asking for is to go the bathroom okay
either you can follow me home no that's
not how that works we need to do the
test here that's fine okay so my partner
is going to read the test allow fine I'm
going to demonstrate the test and then
you're going to perform the test okay so
you're you're denying me the right to
there there's no lawful right to go to
the bathroom you're being denied that
right now cuz we have to perform these
test can we just move this truck a
little
bit sir
really can we just move this truck up a
little bit B I need this I need this
little I need this line sir
I
good the bathroom
please I just have to urinate okay so
please I'm I'm running the F sarar test
now
okay listening okay I'm listening really
put your left foot on the line this is
this is going to be the line while you
walking keep your arms at your size
watch your feet at all times and count
your steps out loud can yeah I I can
hold your wallet for you that's no
problem once you start walking do not
stop until I until you have completed
the test
but I have to urinate sir and I'm
telling you I count the first step from
Heel To Toe position as
one do you understand hold on I have to
urinate I understand what you're asking
but I have to urinate sir I have
okay and I have to urinate and as i' as
I said maybe a thousand And1 times right
now there there's nowhere for you to go
to the bathroom right now I'm fine but
I'm 5 minutes from my house okay I I
know but we just crashed right here and
we can't just let you go so can I ask
your question where did I crash into sir
uh I don't know your car is in the
middle of their driveway and you just
ran over all that stuff what did I run
over okay we're we're going to perform
the right here are you ready ma'am are
you what did I run into are you ready to
conduct the test my ask my question is
to did I run into you don't know that I
don't know how else you exp that to you
you know we're not speaking the same
languages right now so we're performing
the test right now okay perform the test
as you've been instructed are you ready
ma' what I'm asking are you ready
perform the test as you've been
instructed are you ready yes sir begin
so it does not matter that I did not run
into any perform the test ma' my
question ma'am perform the test I'm not
I'm telling you I'm not answering your
question so do the test you're denying
me the right to go to the bathroom sir
yes I yes you're being denied right now
thank you so please perform the test
that you've been instructed so what are
you asking me sir ma'am I already
instructed you how the test is supposed
to as I've explained before no your
short on your left foot on the line and
you're going to go heel the toe two 3 4
5 six 7 8 N9 turn
around one 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 nine okay
second
test it's called the one leg stand so
sir stand with your feet reason why I
ask a question no no you cannot please
stand with your feet together I question
you and please watch me as I perform as
I I'm going to demonstrate the test for
you stand with your feet together and
your arms down at your sides do not
start the test until I tell you to do so
sure when I tell you to begin raise one
leg either one approximately 6 in off of
the ground with your toe pointed out
keep keep both legs straight and your
arms at your Sid sir I have a
that's in your left leg there it's in
both legs it's in both legs wow okay
okay all right whichever one's your best
one we we'll pick that one I cannot do
it sir so you're refusing to do the test
I'm not refusing to do the test when I'm
stating
it unable to participate in that test
try your best I have to urinate and I'm
saying to you that
[Music]
I my doctor all right so and I've
already done it so so real quick sure
are you refusing to conduct this test
right now because of the your whatever
medical conditions I'm say what I'm
stating to you is that I have to use the
bathroom so let me ask you this are you
able to perform this test
due
to I'm unable to
perform the test that you're asking me
to perform so that's both both tests
that's both test okay but I can do what
I need you do okay ma'am just do me a
favor turn around putam behind your
back okay I can do it no sir I can do it
okay it's fine fine no sir I'm fine
please do not pleas I have to go to the
I'm fine you're going be able to go to
the bathroom in a little bit okay I'm
fine you're going to be able to go to
the bathroom very briefly okay CU you're
going to be coming
in to the bathroom I'm F I'm not
refusing please let me you do not want
to catch an additional charge for
resisting arrest I'm not I'm not
refusing to I'm not you you right now
you're refusing under arrest I can do it
I'm asking but I have to go to the
bathroom just put your arm behind your
back okay there we go very good very
good
wow wow I can do the test but I have to
go so that's
that one bra the
central I can do this we got one under
450 I have to go to the back I'm asking
you I can do this test man I have to
just go to the bathroom okay I can I I'm
stating I'm stating that I can perform
the test that's her wallet ma'am is
there anything else in the car you need
to get out right
now perform the test I just need to use
too late it's way too late I can perform
the test going to go back to my I'm
asking you I'm asking you already pass
that point all right come on we already
pass Point come on I'm
stay let's let's let's go over here she
needs to go to asking you if I can
perform the test but I need to go to the
bathroom that's all I'm saying okay all
right and look as soon as we get you
down to HQ you going to use bathrooms no
I can perform the test no no no no
that's stating that that part is over
that part is over I can perform that
part is over just stand right here so my
partner can just pat you down quickly
going
on my father is a retired detective I'm
stating I can perform the test okay I'm
going to meet you at the precinct I
think at this point it's really bill I
have to just go to the bathroom I get it
I'm fine going in the ma do you see
anything that's in that vehicle that
does not belong to you I can perform the
test I'm stating I can perform the test
ma'am get in I'm asking can I perform
the test we're going to bring you to the
bathroom I do not I can perform ma'am
get get in the vehicle get in the no you
cannot that part is over I ask a
question get in the vehicle I have
sir sir officer Feen officer
ma'am you're
making get in the vehicle please get in
the vehicle
wow I get in the
vehicle I can perform the test
sir I can perform the test I just asked
to use the
urination
wow down stand up facing that
wall facing that wall
okay I am
not in tox but I cannot drive okay the
restom is right there the restom is
where the
toilet fingerprints put your back back
in here couple more paperwork and you're
and you're gone you're leaving for the
night we're good okay so if I sign that
no no we're done no no we're done we're
done no more paperwork I'm just and I'm
letting you know no more paperwork we're
done with the paperwork I'm just asking
but I'm helping you out there's no more
paperwork not help there's no more paper
asking and I don't have the right to ask
there's there's no more paperwork we're
done I am not someone that has been in
trouble it doesn't matter I've had
people I've had people that have done
been in the same situation and had not
given me a hard time literally listen to
me listen to me I'm trying to I'm trying
to I'm trying to simplify this as much
as possible trying to understand one
step a Time 20 minute observation 20
minut observation stand the procedures
20 observ that's it if you cannot follow
a daughter of a retired deceased if you
cannot follow my if you cannot follow my
instructions he
asked' sign anything if I if you can
what I'm if you cannot follow my
instructions for the 20-minute
observation if you cannot speak talk
cough whatever if you cannot do that for
20 minutes then I'm going to take that
as a sign of refusal I will take that as
a refusal great so do you understand do
you understand my instructions man do
you understand my instructions no I
don't so so you don't understand what
means to not speak for 20 minutes it's
what I'm asking Officer Louie is I'm
trying to ask for clarification as far
as the procedures the protocol I am
literally telling you what you we have
to do right now don't worry about
everything else I'm literally telling
you right now I'm asking you sit down do
not speak for 20 minutes C whatever
denying not do not worry about the other
paperwork paperwork so at this point at
this point
clarification can Canan you didn't sign
anything the first asking to sign it but
I'm asking for clarification on we're
pass that paper
why are we pass so now' we're back to
the breathalizer
sir why are you denying
me I'm going to make it clear un clear
yes I was arrested for DUI and procedure
for fail his
arrest yes ma'am I mean there's also way
more observations too I'm sorry there's
also way more than just the failed
failed um failed sity test there's also
the accident there's also observation
there's also body language there also no
I'm just I'm just asking so so with all
that with all that with the totality of
with all that the the totality of the
circumstance yes that gave us that so
the S the failed sobriety test okay the
car accident the property damage also
ask me at any time also trying tol I I
understand also
also the observation of their the smell
the the of alcohol as well all right
with all that with all that being said
that gave my partner and the all the
officers the right to put you under
arrest and bring you
in no questions were asked of me other
than to walk the field sobriety no so
what I'm saying is so if I'm walking and
you're walking and we're at an event and
if someone spills alcohol on you MH I
didn't deny that I the fact that I had
not drank okay what I said was I only
had one to two drinks okay that's what I
said Bender will attest to everything
what I'm saying to you is are you
stating that
the the totality of not the
totality that the position
was you place people under arrest for
DUI there was nobody hit there was no
property damage man nobody needs to get
hit or even property damage to get put
under ARR okay so so just so you know
nobody needs to hit a person or anything
for you to get put under summonses they
arrest people yes ma'am for DUI you get
arrested you do there's no summons for
DUI there's you can't just hand out a
ticket for DUI cuz at the end of the day
if you think about it if we're place if
you're if you are if we assume that you
are if you are do at the event to took
me home so you and you should have went
home with them in the first place but
you decided to get behind I couldn't go
home because at that point he asked me
to do a survival test no but ma'am
you're already in the vehicle as soon as
you're in the vehicle you have the full
responsibility of driving safely and
driving not under theforce that is why
so the thing is too we arrested of
people also Under the Influence for
swerving whatever commissioner Luciano
he crashed into a tree man this does not
have I'm just saying to you he crash
left the left the scene I didn't leave
the scene was not arrested that is not
and he was not arrested so I'm just
asking the so the procedure and protocol
for everyone is if they are accused or
thought or suspected to be involved in a
DUI that the process is
for is what I'm asking all right ma'am
your right
here who's
theer 19
you missing one of your shoes man yep
I'm missing both of them but my ad hoc
shoes I have
think
yep
thank
you appreciate
it I don't have any shoes again I didn't
realize I got carpeted I uh it's do you
have paper towel or anything offic
just um
that's the one who that Ro I'm right now
well we can't we not going to win the
fight tonight so can I ask you a
question did you mention to them my
employment because they absolutely said
that they know where I live and where I
work and they claim that you said
it I may have I don't okay but fair
enough yeah I don't fair enough yeah but
I think they they yeah so but the fight
is not going to be one toight I'm not
saying anything right now I'm absolutely
livid I I can tell I can tell I'm livid
I can tell I am yeah I am I'm
sure excuse me he's I'm sorry
man all right so just do me a favor just
read through this it's essentially just
saying that you're responsible for her
mhm okay I'm good with it okay yeah
make sure you read it cuz it tells you I
know I'm not going to let her drive I'm
going take her home the whole n yards if
she gets into a vehicle she's not
driving like that you're all liable for
that got it absolutely completely
understand just uh here
yeah you guys have slippers or anything
for her we do not
unfortunately uh does she have um she
does have shoes in her vehicle
but our vehicle was impounded
okay
uh receiv this potential liability for
law enfor name below okay I got
you
all right and oh I gu refus to ackn my
bad yeah just sorry refusal yeah there
we go what I'm I'm just going to give
you a copy of this as
well bring the you see crashed his car
as no listen
I'm I know it's not going to be B
here
so you go um again let me just copy this
and I'll give you a copy I'll be right
back that's not a problem
sir you clear up C